This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad here with Robert Krulwich.
Cyclo thank you.
This hour we're trying on a way of looking at the world that has nothing to do
with presidents or queens or mayors and everything to do with ants in science.
This is an idea called emergence. How many,
many stupid things can add up to something very smart like a colony or in our
case, a city. Now, speaking of us, it's,
it is often and was often assumed that [inaudible] is a bad thing,
a very dangerous thing.
And this was especially the case in the late 19th century, early 20th,
which is our next stop. It was a time when throughout Europe,
hostile irrational crowds were everywhere in the streets.
You really see this enormous backlash in large part in reaction to, uh,
the rise of democracy. This is James Sheer Wiki author of the book,
the wisdom of crowds.
And he's talking about the people on the other end of the riots,
the intellectual elite. Look at people like Thomas Carlyle, Gustava, Bong,
France, Nicha. Obviously for all these people,
crowds were really the epitome of irrationality institutes
[inaudible] but that was about to change [inaudible] he tells this story of a
guy named Sir Francis Galton. Yeah,
I'm sure Francis Gauld and who was this sort of famous British scientist and is
actually a most famous because he was the founder of what we now know as
eugenics. Oh, is that so, yeah, he's sort of a notorious elitist.
And what's funny is that this is a story about him finding the opposite of,
of his basic assumptions to be true.
Story goes on a nice fall day in 1906 Sir Francis Galton,
the guy who truly believed that only the better classes should be allowed to
vote rule or even have children.
He decides to spend the day in the country.
Ladies and gentlemen, step right this way.
[inaudible] county fair right over here.
Now this is going to be quite an experience for you young man.
The thing that caught Golden's attention that day was a competition involving
and ox.
When you write it on this way,
you might want to avoid that unfortunate property right there. And I didn't
really know. What I want you to do please,
is I want you to examine this very fat ox [inaudible] touch the opposite.
What we do is we look at the ox and we weigh it in our mind.
Yes.
You know, the group was, was, was a really diverse crowd. Family members,
local merchants, most of whom were not experts at all in weighing oxen,
young lady, you know how to weigh a package,
don't you give [inaudible] I carry luggage sometimes that can weigh a package.
Then you can weigh an ox. Here's how you do it. You take a, I don't know, uh,
a couple of packages and put them in your head and say, well,
this all seems to be about 70 packages to multiply the weight of a package by 76
pants. And they would, you know,
make their guests in the people that had the best guesses, woodwind prizes,
large cash prize.
So quite a few people. Yes.
There's something like 800 paper [inaudible] 800 and while none of those 800 or
so people guessed the exact weight of the ox prizes were awarded,
people went home,
but the ever inquisitive Sir Francis Hung around after the contest was over,
excuse me, gotten went up to the organizers. Would you mind Kelly and said,
can I have the guesses if I take possession of all 787 ticket,
you know the slips they had written the guesses on all right, you can have them.
I suppose. I don't see anything wrong with that, but why?
Because I'm wondering something
Caesar. Francis figured these common people wouldn't have a clue.
Most of them were overwhelmingly uninformed.
An expert in bovine matters and he just assumed that if you added up a lot of
uninformed on expert individual opinions, you'd get a very uninformed,
an expert group opinion. That's what he was counting on.
One of the things he did was he just calculated the average gap.
That is the mid point. The me of all the guesses. He figured they'd be way off.
But when he did that,
it turned out that collectively the citizens of Plymouth said the ox weighed
1,187 pounds,
181,187 pounds, hope a cure, which was astonishingly
close. A oxys actual weight was 1,188 pounds.
What else is there a pound off?
They were basically perfect and they were actually better than any single
individual in the group.
Colton was stunned and this went against everything he knew to be true,
but you have to give him credit because he didn't publish the results. He was,
you know, curious enough to acknowledge possibilities
that this experience that, uh, that's gotten had.
We went up to a lot of dumb people and collectively they somehow were smarter as
a group than any one of them.
[inaudible] is an experience that has been experimentally tested over and over
and over. So it, liberal arts colleges all over the United States,
professional liberal arts college because that's where these kinds of things
happen. See, a science professors never happens. Vocational schools.
Just that the liberal arts. Hello. All right.
I'm being a Snob at schools everywhere. A science professor,
a psychology professor usually puts a bowl of jelly beans in front of the room
and says,
how many people here can you just guess the number of jelly beans and over and
over and over again, no one in the room gets the exact number,
but everyone in the room at the mean comes closest.
Somehow the group is smarter than even the smartest kids in the class.
And according to James or Wiki, this is not just a history lesson,
but that it actually is,
is something you can see at work in a lot of other places and can be used to
solve much more complex problems,
much more complex problems. Well, let's just take one example.
The Internet,
if you go back and read a lot of the discussion of the Internet from 1995 to
1998 it was totally dominated by people saying, yeah, the Internet is neat,
but you can never find anything and nobody says that anymore. I mean,
it's just a problem that Google just completely solved.
It's an amazing thing. This if your member is Steven Johnson,
author of the Book Emergence, and here I used that exact same,
the mysterious crowds smarts that was president of the ox guessing contest is
what allowed Google to become such a great search engine almost overnight.
So what Google does
decided to do was to solve the problem of organizing the web in a,
in a bottom up rather than a top down approach.
And what Google said was anytime somebody decides to link to a page,
we're going to count that as a vote,
as a positive endorsement of the page that they're linking to. Oh,
so this is like a little democracy. So it's a little democracy. Exactly.
And so what they said is pages that have a lot of people pointing to them are
going to be more highly valued in the Google kind of system or algorithm than
pages and nobody points to. So if some guy has a blog, which hand,
which is really great and, and a ton of other people linked to him,
he gets in essence what you're saying, a lot of votes. He wins the election.
He went to vote and they added a second layer to it,
which is that when that guy points to somebody else,
his link is more valuable than your average schmoes because a lot of people
point to him too. He has more kind of Google juice.
When you think about the way that city neighborhoods forum,
you asked the question,
where does city neighborhoods come from and the answer is, you know,
well everybody and nobody at the same time as kind of creating this. Yeah.
When you search for something on Google and you get a list of results,
that is often really, really good because Google gives these great results.
Ask Yourself, who decided that this result?
Here is number one in this result is number two. Well,
the answer is everybody and nobody. It's nobody on staff at Google. You know,
Google isn't deciding that this is the premier site for.
If you search for Steven Johnson and this is the second best site,
if you searched for Steven Johnson,
collectively all the people who are offering documents on the web have decided
that this is the best site by choosing to link or not link.
Basically the intelligence of Google is an emergent property of all of these
local decisions to link,
none of which were made until recently with the intent of influencing Google.
Now what's happened recently is that people have started to try and trick. Yeah,
that was my next question to me. You can manipulate, you can manipulate it.
So I, I actually have this experience.
This is one of the most annoying things that's happened to me in the last year.
And it's ironic because it comes out of precisely the thing that I celebrated
and championed and I've been an advocate for them for the last five years. Um,
I have a website that a lot of people linked to and thus I have a
disproportionate power over Google here. When I pointed something,
they will jump up. Yeah, yeah. Have you seen this in, in practical terms? Oh,
absolutely. Well one way you can tell is that for a stretch of time,
if you searched Google for Steven, I was a number one result.
Just Steven just evolved the students in the novel,
Stevenson the world of the Steven Spielberg's is Stephen King's.
I was the number one Steven and obviously on some level Google is wrong in
thinking that I have the number with Steven in the world.
I mean I think very highly of myself,
but I'm not the most important Steven in the road.
But it's because I a website that a lot of other bloggers and people in the kind
of Internet community point to, well maybe you in the mind's eye,
according to Google, I'm no longer Irish. I've dropped to number five or six,
which has been a great tragedy in my life. Who's number one now? Uh, I think it,
last I looked it was this, I think he's a country music star.
Like Steven Curtis Chapman. Yeah, I'm still up there. So you know, it's alright.
But anyway, so because I have this power with Google on my website,
there's an open comment area where anybody can come and post a thought in
response to something that I had posted and about a year ago people started
posting these random kind of nonsense posts that would have a link in at
pointing off to some you know, free Viagra site or to a porn site or to,
you know, kind of get a mortgage, you know, site. It was a coattails thing.
I'm like, this guy is good, so I'm going to get on his coattails. Exactly,
and initially I was like, look,
I don't have that many people coming here that it makes sense to advertise in my
comments area,
but I finally realized that they weren't trying to attract the people who were
hanging out at my site. They were trying to attract Google.
They were talking purely to Google's automated kind of searching.
They were saying, look,
Google will see this as an endorsement from Steven Johnson pointing to this free
gambling site and this is what separates us from the ants right here is we're
aware. Yes, Colon. Yes,
you can step out and play the system because people are smart and they have this
ability to kind of reflect on the system that they're a part of.
We're able to advance faster. But you also have cheats and spoilers.
We'll destroy the system. And I eventually, you know, this is this tragic thing,
but I had to,
I had basically to shut down these conversation areas that I had on my site
because, because these fans,
I would get literally a hundred of these spam posts in a day and a lot of them
were really obscene. So it was like, you know,
my mother would come to my site and be like,
what can you do? What is going on?
Steven Johnson is the author of the book emergence as well as mind wide open and
he's working on a new one,
which will be out soon about how everything that's bad for you is actually good
for you. So it is no surprise that he is currently number four,
Stephen on Google, behind Steven Spielberg, Steven Sonnenburg, Stephen King,
but head of this guy
to
Tuesday the Massey and die.
This is Steven Curtis Chapman saw from a crowd,
even a pretty dumb crowd can emerge magically.
Beautiful complexity.
And this after all was the great insight of Adam Smith wealth of nations seven.
Now you're gonna have to fill me in 1776 he wrote a book in which he proposed
that there's an invisible hand when everybody wants to buy something and
everybody else wants to sell something.
Somehow it all comes together and a perfect balance.
Speaking of which, my name's Ben Ruben,
I'm a sound artist in New York City and what you're about to hear is a piece I
made called open outcry. We'll hear an excerpt.
Silver 44 78
crude oil, 33 two silver, silver
[inaudible] nine zero zero
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
Sometimes I say to people, did you ever bidding? And I know if they say,
I didn't hear you,
I know they're not telling me the truth because people always hear my voice.
It's, it's unique and it's a strong voice too. If I'm selling October's,
you know,
you don't say [inaudible] say [inaudible] and you don't say the full hand.
I'll just say like oc at 10 so I just yell at OCHA 10
oh it's 75 I'm 25 so 25 bucks, 75 bed at 78
seven block seven beds. 25
84 85
by a hundred
yeah. I listen to one person at a time.
You're hearing everybody speak at the same time.
It's like going to a symphony and hearing every piece of the orchestra but yet
hearing the music at the same time and in the midst of that you may observe
instance a broker that you've traded with for years.
You notice face looks like when he's laughing,
you know what his face looks like when he's upset about something at home and
suddenly he's got a nervous look. You can tell when someone is bluffing,
when somebody is not bluffing in this.
These are all skills that are learned over time.
It's really an internal gut feeling.
And as far as just seeing the expression on someone's face,
the way that somebody breathing, the way that somebody leaning on someone else.
I always knew when the guy behind me had a real order. Cause when he had a big,
big order,
he used to take my shoulder and shove it to the ground trying to hold it.
He's too bad. He's too good too. So 50 decent toe.
[inaudible] five to 10 I'll bet no younger. Why he's too big.
Nobody in a half. Nobody. Five and a half.
[inaudible]
so orange juice.
[inaudible] gasoline.
Natural Gas, Huh? [inaudible]
thanks to sound artists,
Ben Reuben and the next big thing for letting us borrow that piece.
Coming up the story of the biggest search and possibly discovery since the
double helix. And it involves the same guy.
I'm Jad Abumrad Robert Krulwich and I will continue in a minute.
You're listening to radio lab. Keep listening. Okay.